Washington Redskins quarterback Josh
Norman how you doing Josh I'm tell you
Josh you know obviously you you you put
everything into it it certainly looked
like you treated it like it was a game
day Josh yeah I mean sure you got there
you got it
you know you gotta come out and perform
I like it is game day so that's exactly
our today and what was the reaction when
you got back to camp
Josh you know guys didn't think I could
actually do what I did really really was
I mean I had couple guys come up and
actually you know partake in it and see
it on those viewers out there doing
dances it and they actually was into it
not even jumped at him when I end up
doing my last dance so it was pretty
cool to have them out there supporting
us and then you know you get our transit
in I pretty much summed up pretty much
my whole entire a little dance off
homeless what do you mean we talked
about well the whole team that I got the
last the last game that we had yeah when
we had all tents when we came up stage
and drip down and the water came down
from the water from the ceiling I know
my guys came out yeah that was great
Josh it really was great watching you do
that this offseason so getting ready for
for this season let's just jump right
into it here how are things different
with Alex Smith at quarterback from your
point of view when you're going against
the ones here he's approaching he knows
where where he can hurt on a football
field so he don't take those chances or
risk and make plays when he gets his
chance
you know if he's not forcing anything
he's going to tape with weakness give
him he's a professional and it blows and
a guy like that you can you know you can
rally behind and in terms of just in in
the locker room this year is there
anything different but with him and
cousins
what do you got for me on that front
once you know both of them different of
course you're gonna have different know
styles to each person you get somebody
else come in
it's my new or somebody those heroes
before you had that compare that
contrast but they both very differently
always both of them have some
similarities and like I said it was both
different too but you know alex is a
winner enemy I said other one Curt isn't
cuz of course he is he where he is Eddie
got what he got but when you coming up
here and get a guy like that he's been
elite longer and he knows what's going
on so it's not like you have the arm
weight or doing thing he does everything
right way and he's in here 24/7 you know
and that's what you like seeing
quarterback and now agent Peterson's
there Josh oh yeah what's that hey all
day is here ad he's in DC yes no ap is
in DC from all day every day it'll be
kind of cool to actually you know see
I'm up close in person see how he no
[ __ ] realize do this thing because
you have an opening for him and he came
through he grabbed it the bull by the
horns and I was gonna see what he do
with it
second day like they'll play you haven't
shaken his hand yet you haven't shaken
his hand yeah yeah okay cuz I'm on our
day off cuz what's your day whenever I
shake his hand I feel like I'm having my
blood pressure taken his hands like one
of those cuffs they put on there to test
your blood runs boss like you can
absolutely since your hands feel like
brick right there clean well I'll tell
you it Josh one of the things that
everybody's talking about right now is
the decline of football because of this
helmet rule that's in place that two
preseason games and people are left
confused fans players in some coaches
where do you stand on the new helmet
rule Josh Norman I'm use myself
I know we had a meeting every day about
that time I'm definitely fused I thought
it was something where you know yours
talk keep your head up and you know go
through and but now that I'm looking at
what's going on it you can't play
football man
you just cannot play football I don't
know how you're gonna tell somebody but
I can't being part of it that's what the
game was made for so I we understand
what we signed up for we get it but at
some point of time you got to stop
babying cats cause right now that's what
the league's doing they just keep
putting and implementing the rules on
the game that's already great like what
are you doing taking away from what's
already been you know here before and I
get the whole concussion rule and you
trying to stop all that but at the end
of the day man we scrapbook we know what
it is
liabilities there we have to play
football well it's made to do what the
game was created to do and and they like
desk that's what it is you know what I
mean is injuries and things like that a
nature is going to happen because it's
such a violence court you can't put them
on TV and don't think you're not gonna
get violence because that is what's
gonna happen I mean if you don't want to
watch it turn away I mean not gonna get
more your shield by doing it you know
it's obviously gonna be the traffic
there's gonna be the opposite update I
mean it's gonna take you to ship away
view and look at there's no football or
something else so I'm going on about
this is it subject good no I I know I'm
wondering how do you respond them when
you see for instance Bill Belichick
saying there's not a problem here
because we don't teach that form of
tackling and then other coaches are
saying you know we'll take a look at the
video and players will adjust the league
saying we're gonna just keep on sending
video to make sure players understand
and they will eventually adjust it'll be
a period of adjustment
do you think that's not possible
but we'll have to work it all out of it
look at me your head is gonna be
involved in any kind of contact and it's
gonna get to a point where something's
on line a big gang wars situation online
and then that plate comes into effect
and then you get a call that's obviously
not what it looks like on TV and Dan
that call stands you move a team into
field goal and George touch now
opportunity and that is your ball game
man yeah you're gonna have fans Vegas
and everybody else it's somebody's book
so I don't know man it's it's tough it
really is tough to play defense down
football in this new league of the
offense because how can you how can you
actually play the game and even for rent
backs on your head they gonna call them
too so I don't really know how you play
the game anymore to that sense when you
look at it I know what they say and all
you have is Justin it's not how you
adjust to what the game is it is a
professional football game that's what
you get you get in violence with a
little bit of flair that goes along with
it
if you can avoid it great you can't
that's a part of the game that's a part
of the game how many change dealing one
I'm he's gonna take it just like the cat
have nine lives
that's about using some of them because
in a day that's what you're gonna get
when you come to this game you got to
know that I understand it and I guess
guys up there you know they make these
rules and they come down with them
that's what they do blue okay I can't
say we already been gotta do is we going
for but don't fedexes I hope you didn't
mean it come into the boxes here cuz
that's gonna be a problem
yeah I know you're not referring to the
field that your home field you're
referring to some of the fines and and
missives that come from the league that
dips into pockets Matt Josh Norman had
the Lou
Josh Norman here on the Rich Eisen show
of one last on this subject then
what was the meeting like I mean you
said that there was a meeting on this
subject was it a team meeting was it
just a defensive back meeting where
their league officials will walk a fan
through what that meeting looks like I
mean he'll the meetings where you know
it was discussed it was brought up and
then we had a conversation about it and
in that conversation you know we pretty
much know voicing my opinion going and
seeing what you know we can do to try to
you know I'm trying to move around the
subject or not around a subject blare
around you know how to place you know a
clean hit on another you know offender
and they're like how to do that like we
had a breakdown of it and I just from
the conclusion of it all who kind of was
like you know a little bit shuffled by
it was kind of confused like oh my
goodness how are we really gonna do this
like taking guys out low but then you
leave my chairman in and then what you
turn around you take guys out you know
which a shoulder pad your helmet still
is gonna be a part in it so I saw we saw
in the video here an appreciate game
where I think I'm 23 or another team he
led with his put a shoulder pad and I'm
torch his I guess the guy horse or
whatever and his head was in there but
he let his shoulder pad he got called a
15-yard penalty for that like a personal
foul so I was looking at like how are
you gonna play this so called fan
perspective I would take into
consideration we're doing everything he
can as players to read game safe but
also protect ourselves and make a play
for our team
last one that's the same thing last one
for you Josh cuz I know we you got a run
here what did you think of Jalen
Ramsey's question-and-answer with GQ
where he was very honest and his
assessment of what he wore at least it
honest and
in his inner in delivering his inner
monologue on quarterbacks in the league
brutally honest bet to what you would
say right well yeah so I guess what you
think we were you amused were you a
little jealous that he yeah but you were
just freedom freedom you know give it a
platform on a magazine to just talk
about which quarterbacks are you give a
platform tacitly yes you know without it
really didn't care for but a rose wrote
so it is what it is but at the same time
I think Oh younger we do things and we
come in and we have our mindset on stuff
but we need it older you start look at
things and see how to affect other
people and be like oh but I don't know
that was his that was what he said and
what he believed to be truth in his eyes
okay everyman it types a talent paint
don't matter what it is so yeah for sure
that's how he felt about it
okay I know those courses was next to me
so I can't okay Josh does that Prescott
suck Josh Norman yes or no so you're not
taking any bait is what you're saying
okay you know sonic you skin but no
I respect their real point I go yes and
you should already know me I don't
really go out the water seeps I really
don't I go over quarterbacks wanted that
deliver on the ball I like to play chess
though with guys because you can beat
them you be the wire receivers because
he's willing to run the ball so I always
like to challenge those guys and see
whoever the top of a game who's not
maybe our tell somebody that hey you're
doing are right knowing that he really
sucks but baby sucks so therefore he
would have his confidence hi the we're
okay he says I'm good to me I'm gonna
come at him
great that's what I want you to do but
you actually suck I'm not gonna say that
you know please look at mount game
I'll play the head games with the guy
put in the Damned like alright you did a
great job
so are you were doing with Donald this
week with the Jets you got Jets fans all
excited talking about how good you
stopped it no I was truthful about Sam
Donnell I really was me and when you sit
back there and you watch him how he was
methodical is approach I don't know what
the guy's gonna tell us that I don't
know I don't get him taller I didn't get
into the how you did speed keep dancing
you know he was poised back there well
young guy man coming into the league or
nothing but dogs people just want to get
after you like that and it's so much
faster in the windows are so much
tighter he was able to do some things
that really impressed me man and I
really don't do that and you see that
you want to play all working back you
know that from day one you want coming
here and Barriss him make him feel so
bad but with him needed took it Tom and
just you know deliver the ball and gave
what the defense you know he took what
it because game from he was really good
actually
I couldn't hate welcome at the man
pretend I was like okay cool man is
pretty sweet awesome to see Josh love
our chats my kid like I said my kid is
exactly who you were cuz he's obviously
follows your work in a football field he
saw him it's a couple of Disney shows
from time to time and I've been watching
you dance it was great showing my kid
what you could do out there on the floor
the rest of America watch to a man is
much more to being a football player you
know so much more than that
it's the face right here plays actuality
it is a big world out there Jesus guy
goings good then I'm glad I'm glad you
weren't using the the crown of your head
while dancing because I would have they
wouldn't like they would have flag
during that trap okay actually I did in
the warm-ups if they show that replay
why kind of climb one of my guys wiped
him out Josh but it looked clean it
looked clean though it looks clean
unreal of our chats you take care of
Josh right back at you Josh Norman at
Jay underscore no.24 the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience